is there
some broader understanding of how we
should think about alien intelligences
than um like little green men yes
that um that you can maybe elaborate on
and talk about
yes this comes directly out of my
research in catholic history
what i found was that let's take for
instance this idea of an angel
okay so we all think we know what an
angel looks like why well we've been
told what an angel looks like
we see what an angel looks like
throughout history people have painted
angels and they all look pretty much the
same
but actually if you go to the primary
sources on
you know either in hebrew or in greek or
you know in whatever language and in
latin
and you look at experiences that people
have
talked about you know where they've
written down their experiences about
angels
um angels don't at all look like what we
think
they they don't look like little cherubs
with wings they don't look like tall
you know strong
[Music]
anthropomorphic you know human looking
things they don't
they look really weird and sometimes
they don't
look at all a humanoid and they look
like
strange spinning things right with like
you know
eyes and things like that they they
communicate telepathically
with us okay so what does that mean for
the idea of
extraterrestrials or what we consider to
be aliens like
um i do think that
there first if we are if listen
is i'm not the first to say this if
we're in contact with
non-human intelligence we're most likely
in contact with its
technology because think about us
um do we send human beings to mars yet
some people say yes
but let's put that aside so no we don't
we use our technology we send our rovers
to mars okay okay so if there's an
extraterrestrial
civilization is it sending are they
coming
by themselves are they coming to see us
or are they sending their technology
most likely
they either are technology or they are
sending their technology yeah there
might be a gray area between what is
technology and what the aliens are
yeah so but you're saying like uh
basically a robotic
probe that would be the equivalent of us
our human civilization created
technology way more way more advanced
than what we could
believe to be a probe all right it's
kind of funny you think about
like if uh whatever uh
sort of um
extraterrestrial creations have visited
earth
that we're we're interacting with some
like
dumb crappy drones yeah it's true
and we're like like
we're like building these like myths and
so on from like an experience with some
like crappy drone made by some crappy
startup something that's correct
when the actual intelligence is like
something
much grander um yeah that's that's
that's the more likely uh the situation
is what i like to tell people i'm like
no
it's probably a lot weirder than you
think yeah oh boy
so uh but what forms can it possibly
take so
yeah okay i really love this idea that
um
i tend to be humble in the face of all
that we don't know
and i tend to believe that the form
alien
life forms would take and the way they
would communicate
is much more likely to be of a form that
we can't even comprehend or perhaps
can't even perceive
directly so like you know
uh it could be in the space of you know
we don't understand most of
how our mind works it could be in the
space of whatever the heck consciousness
is
like maybe consciousness itself is
communication
uh with aliens or like
i don't know it could be just our own
thoughts is actually the alien life
forms
communicating like i i know all that
sounds crazy but i'm saying like
i'm just trying to come up with the
craziest possible thing that doesn't
make any sense that could very well be
true
and you can't say it's not true because
we don't understand basically anything
about our mind
so it can be all of those things uh
everything from
hallucinations all the things that are
explored through
uh through the different drugs that
we've
uh talked about in this podcast in
general joe rogan loves to talk about
dmt and all those kinds of
hallucigenic drugs all of it
including love and fear
all those things that could be aliens
communicating with us memes on the
internet that could be
pretty sure humor is alien communication
no i don't know
but uh so is there some way that's
helpful for you
to think about beyond the little green
men oh absolutely
it um it occurs exactly with how i think
actually
um so i'll explain and
i liked in american cosmic i attained
the status of full professor
so i was like okay i can pretty much
write this book like i want to do it and
i did
so i used a lot of quotes from cool
artists like david bowie
okay so david bowie opens the book okay
and he basically says and so does
nietzsche by the way david bowie and
nietzsche
boom two two awesome quotes right
together that's how i open the better
opener
yeah do you remember the quotes yeah of
course so the first the
quote by david bowie and that's what i'm
going to concentrate on in response to
what you just said which i think is
absolutely correct um david bowie said
the internet is an alien life form
okay and if you've not seen david
bowie's interview
where he says that i highly recommend it
he's so brilliant okay so david bowie is
actually quite brilliant about
the idea of ufos he's also brilliant
about the idea of technology
okay and most people wouldn't think that
but i mean he's
pretty darn smart okay so all right
so i started to think about it and uh i
also early on in my research met
jacques valet okay so he's a
technologist uh he has
a phd in information technology from
computer science basically
from northwestern and he got that back
in the day you know when i say back in
the day i'm not talking a thousand years
ago
i'm talking like in the 60s okay so he's
back when computer science wasn't really
even the future yeah
you can get a degree yeah he has a phd
in it
and he's french he's from france but he
lives in silicon valley
and he worked on arpanet which is the
proto-internet
uh he mapped mars he's also an
astronomer i mean he's just this
all-round brilliant guy right
and he's also interested in ufos and
most people
take those two interests of his as
separate interests and
i remember being at a very small
conference and listening to him
being in awe of course because he's an
awe-inspiring person
and then thinking wait a minute why do
people
compartmentalize those two things about
him they're one and the same okay
so when we talk about ufos and uaps and
stuff
we have to talk about digital technology
and things like that
now if we're going back to what i
so if i were to say what if i were to
believe in
and i like i said earlier i was agnostic
bordering on belief
most likely a believer in these this
extraterrestrial or
not extraterrestrial let me put it
another way non-human intelligence
that's communicating with us
i'm going to tell you how i think they
communicate with us and i go back to the
greeks again
okay and the greeks had this idea of
muses
you know the muses so okay so there are
these things called muses
and we tend to think of them as
metaphors right but what if they're not
whether actually non-human intelligence
trying to communicate with us but we're
so stupid
we can't like understand like so only
people with like
you know in super amazing um
capacities like poetic creative
you know intelligent mathematical
whatever you know because they tend to
do this symbolically they tend to
communicate with us in symbols form
and so music you know symbols we've got
math that are you know it's a symbolic
language
and so what so okay so muses are
probably a good
idea for me of what this would be now
would muses have
spaceships you know or those things that
we call physical
counterparts to what they are
that's another question altogether
you